[Music]
in raining fuel news submitted by camels
Hawk the FAA is reported that Delta jet
dumped fuel over LA without warning
doing an emergency landing I've heard
about this heard what landed on - really
it's [ __ ] crazy I want to know
everything about her to land on a bunch
of school kids yeah plane I was like
just dump it all over a [ __ ] Lake
Elementary School in Cudahy and what
could I hate the city of cutting it all
this is right there
yes - the south gate and bail exactly
imagine she decided to dump it
we're all the Mexicans are already brown
you don't really see it then that's what
the kind of a Mexican kids what colors
jet fuel
are they brown okay very Latin Brown I
think there were five elementary schools
in one high school goddamn they did just
specifically target up the headline not
at the reality yeah yeah because it was
you laughed at the reality you're so
happy that minorities are suffering
that's good chip how do you spill fuel
in a circle shape and it comes out of
hits only those sign things like a
dusting dusters yeah orange would they
like to dump it so when they land it
just in case it would explode because
they were gonna land like a weight in
commercial exactly
so they're saying that it was a safety
issue as to why they needed to dump fuel
but see there's a lot of issues going on
because they're saying okay so here's
the thing the pilot said to air traffic
control they said it's a brain percent
it's a proverb over okay it's a prank
broach prank received man no so the
pilot said we've we've got it back under
control we're going to come back to LAX
we're not critical we're going to slow
to 280 knots and why don't you point us
downwind at 8,000 feet and we'll turn
back to LA and then the tower said okay
so you don't need to hold or dump fuel
or anything the pilot said negative
Roger that dumping fuel so then the FAA
said that the air traffic controller he
should not have used the word don't when
he asked oh because there's a
conversational yet specific terms right
so his sentence was okay so you don't
need to hold or dump fuel or anything
like that so that exact sentence should
been broken English what are they
supposed to say oh I mean that's really
gone like over radios you go like
negative or affirmative you're not
supposed to say no yes it's to like
supposed to say how do you feel I think
you know I'm pretty scared right now I'm
[ __ ] terrified right now and you're
supposed to fly like so so the situation
is a failure to communicate and that the
air traffic controllers should have
asked the question without holding about
holding or dumping fuel without using
the word don't and he should have
repeated the questions I mean that's
pretty nitpicky dang
so the fact that the plane was was lower
than 8,000 feet that's the reason why
the fuel was dumped onto people because
if they were higher it would have a
otama die
Adam Adam on Adam I know what the word
is don't know it means it like it
vaporizes pretty much like the ocean are
they supposed to sprayed into the ocean
so they're saying that there are no
losers yeah that there are procedures if
something like this happens that the air
traffic control will designate a
specific area where they could dump fuel
like Lancaster no one cares about that
[Laughter]
just on the way to Lancaster like
literally just getting off with a five
you like this right here this is the
flight path so they're saying that as
soon as they took off there was
something wrong so then they had to turn
back around but they there and then the
fact that the pilot specified that it's
not critical yeah he should have known
that he had to dump fuel before landing
because it's not safe to dump or to land
when the plane is so heavy because they
were heading to Shanghai those a lot
[ __ ] yeah that's a lot of fuel dump on
kids soaked like it's my dubs a bottle
water use like all right that must feel
like will break your neck the changes
appeals through your chest no kids were
saying that they were like oh I thought
it was raining oh no they open their
mouth not know it yeah not know yeah
gross nothing one kid said like yeah my
friend was saying that he thought it was
raining but then I didn't see any clouds
and then I started feeling like it'd be
wet and then I could smell it that it
smell like gasoline
we're babies and what if it burned yeah
I was gonna say like what if one kids
just like to start a life what I know
they're saying that one of the little
kids got some in his eye so there were
about 60 people that got affected with
this he says but none of them were
hospitalized so that's thank God I feel
like this shirt check no they did get
like like fully Delta some t-shirts yeah
okay you get your wings yeah you're
flattered for these guys yeah yeah so
they ended up having I believe six
cleanup crews - oh it was 1 / 1 / school
less our lives
poor guys out in fields [ __ ] wiping
grass down with rakes
that's all you can do that's it yeah so
they're saying that this plane which was
carrying 149 passengers and 15 crew
members landed safely it's just
unfortunate that they had to dump them
so the air traffic controller [ __ ] up
by saying don't it's not just that but
then they're also saying that the wrong
link we'd like based off of where they
dump the fuel it was very apparent that
the flight crew realized last minute oh
[ __ ] we need a dump fuel before we land
because they were about to land in the
airport and the I guess they didn't I
for whatever reason they didn't want to
circle back around to the airport again
- like don't come the toss over the
ocean for a little bit at the same time
I think so I don't know I don't know
exactly what what the circumstances are
but they are investigating it actually
yeah they have found that they did not
ask for permission to dump witches it's
not a regulation or anything but usually
they would be asking hey where can we -
I know
flying over [ __ ] la million people
down that did they say like what
emergency they had they didn't specify
they were interesting that they just
needed to come back
emergency we have too much fuel yeah
there was just some sort of like some
sort of issue that required them to turn
back I don't really my little brothers
an air traffic controller so I will be
asking him about this
if I find it very interesting that
saying don't saying a certain thing is
yes the phrasing of it is like oh that's
frowned upon
yeah maybe maybe was because of the way
the census was constructed it sounds
like yeah so you don't need to dump or
hold anything right yeah versus like so
you don't need to dump or hold anything
just land right like depending on the
tone and inflection and it could be two
different sentences so yeah then the
pilot responded with a negative so he's
like about I don't know what you're
asking me but negative you h- wait why
is he cut a [ __ ] about it if he did dump
fuel he's like oh yeah I think I took
care of it back no we are clear there's
experiencing trouble but they had
cleared it up and it was not critical so
they've just a lot of people are like
then why do what you did like not scary
I'm so glad I've never been in like an
emergency on the flight if there were
take an ounce it on their plan wife but
it's oh man I'm already scared enough on
planning I mean I haven't been I haven't
been in the emergency but I've been on
some like some rough landings yeah just
carry back yeah yeah rough surveillance
Gary well was that cover was in Europe
because I know that that Europe the
Atlantic flights are pretty rough no
actually you know what it was Monday I
just came back from Santa has a sack
this past weekend and the pilot land is
so hard the [ __ ] language switched on
announcements
that's how like I feel like the hood
Kells came off the plane I was just like
it was like I'm using like what do you
do it
like I was legit upset and wanted to
talk to City - did it bounce like you
could feel like I was like this ain't
like like you say it's not a long trip
it wasn't a huge planes or like I don't
know maybe just came in - I'm trying to
pop tires on coming everything anything
is possible I mean one of these
scenarios work yet there's no like none
of them true so the people reporting and
even the people in charge of the
elementary schools they were just saying
like listen we're not judging we don't
know what the hell you had to go through
in the air to make these decisions at
all and they and then other media
outlets have said like yeah in the past
it's just it's been very very dangerous
to land a plane with a lot of weight and
it gets the point where like it could
[ __ ] up the tires and it could just it
could be good catastrophic so yeah yet
it's a here moment we said [ __ ] these
kids yeah please don't literally dump on
these kids just socioeconomically scar
them for life yeah but they're also
talking about how there was this other
flight where was it I remember reading
about it but they were just talking
about this other flight where there were
a whole bunch of people in it and
everyone died I thought that was going
they didn't dump the fuel I believe so
[ __ ] I forgot I'm saying this off the
top of my head and I can't find it in
these articles to article well do they
live or die they die the story of this
other plane but I forgot the detail so
really this article should just be
rephrased as hero pilots
[Laughter]
[Music]